that's great that you're getting ready
for all these things that might happen
maybe one day but you're 150 pounds
overweight and you don't even know how
to use a defibrillator they don't like
it when you tell them that but that's
the real threat i'm just gonna jump on
my rooftop with all my guns and it's
like how the hell are you gonna get up
you know
i mean i'd like to see a try
sean ryan welcome to the show thanks for
having me you got a hell of a show here
thank you man i appreciate that thank
you
navy seal
cia contractor
personal security expert
guy that helped train keanu reeves to be
john wick
that the headlines those are the big
ones that's that's the big ones yeah yep
good what's keanu reeves like in real
life he is very soft-spoken
uh he's a very
good listener
very good student we didn't really trade
too many stories or anything he just
came out to train and
and i kept it extremely professional and
um but he was he's
a very intelligent guy he picks things
up really quick he's serious about what
he's doing
and uh he's honestly he's one of the
best
students or people that i've ever
trained he just really picks up on
things what makes a very good student of
somebody that wants to learn about
protection weapons
aggression precision it doesn't take
much it takes a good listener
in that industry you get a lot of people
that come out
who
have been they like to say they've been
shooting since they were five or
they've been hunting since they were
you know were walking
and they always have these stories and
it's this is how i do it this is how
i've always done it but when you get a
guy like
keanu
or a lot of women are like this too they
just they're like a sponge they just
retain they listen they retain the
information
and
all they're worried about is what you're
saying doing it for what you're doing
and that's what makes a good student
it's not
with shooting it's not you know you
don't need to be an athlete you don't
need to be super intelligent or anything
like that you just need to be able to
listen
and and
be able to retain information and set
your ego aside
i did a firearms and fitness course at
atomic legion out here in austin so they
do uh weapons training they've got a
grand master shooter on the books guy
called alex acosta's a [ __ ] animal
and uh
we did this firearms and fitness thing
so picking up a sandbag do two laps dump
the sandbag take three shots if you hit
the three shots you get more shots and
scores and within this time window and
you can extend the time window if you're
more accurate and all this sort of stuff
and uh i had my ass handed to me by
like
mothers of three 55 year old mothers of
three because they're able to i was
fitter than them but their ability to be
precise and to be able to control
themselves under pressure
uh and obviously the shooting experience
which being a brit i haven't got tons of
but yeah it was it was fascinating to
see and then those videos of keanu it's
from what was it five years ago six
years ago when those ones went like
hyper hyperviral from taran it's been a
it's been a while yeah but the one where
he was switching between all of those
different weapons he's got that is yeah
that was the first i think that was the
first
john wick oh okay so he's been that
skilled and then probably got even more
skill as he keeps going through yeah i
can't take credit for teaching him how
to shoot i taught him how to clear a
room okay and what what was the what
were the main things that you're trying
to get him to be accurate with that i
just wanted to help him look realistic
when he was entering a room or kicking
doors and you know because it's a
fast-paced
very
action
movie and so i wanted to help bring a
realistic standpoint that's what i got
asked to do out there taryn asked me to
just teach him how to clear a room so i
said all right let's do it cool man so i
had this uh i saw this news article i
wanted to have a chat with you about so
this is from bloomberg critics and fans
have never disagreed more about movies
when sony released its film adaptation
of the video game uncharted in february
critics were kicked quick to tear it
apart the wall street journal called it
bloodless heartless joyless sexless and
with one exception charmless new york
magazine deemed it curiously empty
moviefreak.com dismissed it as a
bonafide disaster and yet audiences ate
it up the movie which stars tom holland
and mark wahlberg opened to a 44.2
million dollar the box office and went
on to gross 401
million worldwide it's one of the 10
highest grossing movies of the year
uncharted also initiated one of the
biggest disputes between critics and
fans in modern movie history audiences
have given high scores and critics to
all 10 of the year's biggest movies the
average audience score for jurassic
world dominion on rotten tomatoes and
imdb is 67 the critic score is 34. so a
difference of 33 points the grey man is
the same uncharted is the same
disagreeing by more than 30 points it
may seem as though critics
typically panned the year's biggest hits
but that's not the case sometimes
audiences tend to give blockbusters high
scores it can also be the other way
around the thing that i think is
interesting about this is how
detached
the people in positions of power whether
that be in media whether that be in
legislature
the
gap between what the normal person likes
and enjoys and wants
and what the critics
think that they should want perhaps or
what they believe would be good for the
plebians to actually want
seems to be diverging more and more what
do you think i 100 agree with you on
that
i i feel like there's an agenda
you know behind everything that comes
out now and
i don't know exactly where that comes
from but it is not from
the audience
and i think it's it's disconnected
hollywood so much that i mean it hurt
their bank accounts
real bad
and and you're starting to see
more a-list celebrities moving
to the podcast world because nobody's
watching their movies anymore they're
starting to see them move into amazon
and netflix series and not hollywood
you're starting to see them uh produce
their own stuff
because
nobody's watching nobody's watching that
stuff anymore because it was so agenda
well we saw this with i think it was the
oscars last year that most of was it
nomadland i think that cleaned up it
might be in the oscars or the golden
globes one of the
awards ceremonies
and all of the films that were doing
well in the box office you can all it's
almost an inversion if it does well in
the box office it's probably not going
to do well at the awards and if it does
well at the awards it's probably not
going to do well in the box office i
think the last one someone brought it up
that did manage to do both was dark
knight batman
um but yeah when you think about
all the marvel movies stuff like that
the only one that got rated well was
black panther
great movie
but there's an agenda there yeah right
you know it's a signal to people
i i part of me
look i i do understand the whole
diversity thing but when when you make
it the point of the movie to shove
diversity down everybody's throat
it doesn't work and then you look at a
movie like top gun that came out
everything was in there right it was
there was all the diversity but that
wasn't the point of the movie the point
of the movie was
fighter pilots
the usa
you know it was very
i think it was a very patriotic movie
and look what happened it was it just
smashed everything in its way and
everything that needed to be in there to
make everybody happy
was in there
you know
and and i think that's
that should be the example my friend
douglas has a
an idea about how you can tell when a
minority is fully
absorbed into a culture and he says it's
when you have to put up with the same
amount of [ __ ] that everybody else does
and that's a great quote it's a lovely
way to think about it right the fact
that what you actually want is for
people to not care anymore to not care
the fact that you're black or gay or
trans or
disabled whatever right that is the
position you want to get yourself into
and you know that when there is a degree
of just day-to-day [ __ ] that you
have to put up with that everybody else
does too and i think that you're right
when um diversity is made a point it
almost seems patronizing to the people
that it's trying to
uh put at the forefront it's like well
you
your position in society isn't
sufficiently deserving or you wouldn't
be given this if we didn't make it a big
deal it's like no no like you just
if the lead actor is a black man let's
not how about we don't reference the
fact that he's black exactly how about
he's just the lead guy and you see this
with the james bond discussion right all
the time like what would it be like to
have the first female james bond or the
first black james bond or the first gay
james bond or whatever yeah
why don't you just make a new series a
new james bond whoever's the good james
bond so
yeah it's um
it's an interesting one man i think that
the more the elites become out of touch
with what normal people want
the
more that you're going to see
the less faith normal people are going
to have
in what they do
i think that's why
i think that's why youtube and and and
podcasting is getting so big because
it's the it's
one of the only spaces left that's
i guess semi-unfiltered right yeah
unmolested yeah
so
it's it's sad to see it go that way but
it's been going that way for a long time
and um
but hey it's good for us right one of my
friends sent me that news article he
said the spiraling lunacy of elites
shows up in the most benign places you
know right the rotten tomatoes is pretty
[ __ ] benign as far as it goes but
yeah man it'll be interesting to see
what happens and you
one of the problems you have is with a
medium like podcasting
and even instagram stories to a degree
as well what you got with instagram
stories was a very unfiltered look at
people that were super super high status
so you got to see what
kanye west's dog was called right or
like kim kardashian's starbucks order or
whatever like it doesn't matter about
what it is the point being that it gave
you a degree of transparency into the
lives of people that previously would
have been so untouchable
but that kind of
that transparency means that people need
to be more real because our ability to
tune in to whether or not someone is
bullshitting us has been now filtered
and filtered and filled a lot more
tightly so you see somebody come out and
try and give some press conference or
you even watch you know a late night
show now where you've got the two-minute
segment to get out what it is that you
need to get out and it just feels so
strange it almost feels scripted and it
might be you know all the
you guys have the late night shows we
don't quite have the same thing over
here where they'll come on and say oh so
are you going to do a squirrel
impression let me see your squirrel
impression like yo you you prepped
[ __ ] squirrel impressions
backstage before you do this and it just
seems so clunky and
it doesn't surprise me that people don't
have faith
yeah i 100 agree with you on that i also
i don't know how to say this lightly but
i feel like the population is just
getting
dumber
and i think if you look at some of the
stuff because i i mean we're both you
know in the same space um basically
and so i'm always studying
social media what's taking off what's
not taking off
and and looking at you know everybody
else what's taking off for them
and when i see if you go to youtube
trending you know or you look at what
the explorer tab is going to show you on
instagram or tip top
it's mindless [ __ ]
it
it doesn't there's it doesn't make any
sense and
when it comes to
podcasts like yours and like mine i mean
there's some deep discussions that
happen and you have to pay attention
and
i don't think
i think there's a
percentage of the population that cannot
comprehend the conversation he's
starting to have a diverging group there
as well that being said
people want whatever is effective and i
think that
the people that are able to pay
attention that are able to
have interesting conversations and
learn about a point of view that they
maybe don't agree with without losing
their [ __ ] at it
those people will end up being in a much
better place in life so
the people that don't have that are
going to fall behind and people model
the behavior of people that are
successful
so i'm hoping that you will lead from
the front the people that are prepared
to accept their own ignorance and say i
don't know what do you teach me i'd love
to find out about
rotten tomatoes or whatever how we're
going to engineer human dna for space
flight or whatever the [ __ ] it is
my friend the same guy actually that
sent me that article's got a theory that
he calls the midwit appeal theorem by
definition most people are midwits
therefore nothing can achieve mass
significance without appealing to and
allowing itself to be explained by
midwits if that's the bulk of the area
under the curve people that
think that they have a degree of smart
but don't know just how dumb they are
that means that all of the stuff that
takes off is going to appeal to them by
definition and if you're out on the
tails it can make you feel a bit lonely
this is something i had when i was back
in the uk a little bit i was like i have
all of these interests and i kind of
don't really have many people to talk to
about them that kind of sucks um but
then you find oh hang on there is a huge
community of people in the world that
want just to learn about stuff
constantly the rest of their life until
they're dead yeah always learning always
curious yeah
it's awesome so
i was thinking about all of the stuff
that you've done throughout your career
seals cia personal security
a lot of those things
there is there seems to be two types of
narratives to do with people that go to
war
one is that it's one of the most
important things that we do
sending these people on the front lines
but then there is also situations like
withdrawal from afghanistan like lack of
success in other areas especially in the
middle east for america
and there was a question that i thought
of which is do you think it's more scary
that everything that you do matters or
that nothing that you do matters
that's a good question
i would rather everything matters
um i i don't know
i don't know what it would be like if
nothing mattered
um i would think that would be a very
unfulfilling way to live would you agree
yeah
yeah so
even right now i think everything that i
do
matters
so
i i can't i don't
for me i i wouldn't be happy if i was
doing stuff that i didn't think mattered
it would be a very unfulfilling life
it's a dangerous position to get
yourself into
that's where nihilism starts to creep in
i mean what do you
what do you feel good about if nothing
you're doing matters you're just i mean
we see it all the time you know people
just skating by but
i don't think they really have anything
good
you know to feel about or they're not
really proud of anything and and uh
i would that would bother me a lot
it's a way to escape though because
there's a pressure associated with
having everything that you do mata
right and an easy way to escape from
that is to say well look nothing does i
don't need to take responsibility for
everything and there's a bunch of ways
that people can escape from this you
know whether it's not believing that
free will exists whether it's believing
that
humanity is a curse on the earth and is
doomed and that we need to
limit our ecological impact as much as
possible
whichever route you go down from the
philosophical to the ecological to the
scientific to the transhumanist
all of these are different ways i think
to
make people feel better about the fact
that they're scared that nothing that
they do matters
yeah i you know
i've heard you talk a lot about
psychedelics on here and i've done
psychedelics
for treatment not for fun
and i will say that
before i did that treatment everything
was a huge deal even the things that i
didn't think were a huge deal
or i'm sorry even things that i thought
that were a huge deal after i did
the psychedelic treatment i realized
you know
not all this [ __ ] isn't a is as
important as i gave you some perspective
it gave me a lot of perspective that i
needed would you mind
explaining what you did in terms of your
course of treatment
uh i did i did ibogaine
have you heard of that
i did ibogaine and then i did five meo
and i did that about six months ago
when i did it i haven't i haven't drank
since i saw you did a thousand days
clean i did yes and um i haven't had a
drop of alcohol i haven't had a drop of
coffee my anxiety
is gone i struggle with that a lot
my anger issues are gone and i i really
struggled with that a lot uh coming out
of the military in the agency and just
getting back into civilian life and so
and it helped me become more in the
moment which was my primary reason to go
do that was a uh i now have a
one-year-old
and uh i just wanted to be
in the moment with him would you class
whatever it was that you were feeling
like as ptsd or is this
a
how would you say
a conditioned response to life from
being a high level operator for a long
time
both yeah i think both
head injuries ptsd
what head injuries where the head
injuries come from in your line of work
uh
blown up
falling out of helicopters stuff falling
out of helicopters how high
oh maybe 10 feet okay no not too crazy
but a little higher enough enough to
land on your head and then yeah
what about what's blowing up mean when
you've been blown up
i've been blown up in sniper hides
where
we've been mortared
and you're just getting these
concussions you're blowing doors you
know you're when you're when you're in a
seal team when you enter
a room a lot of times there's a
explosive charge that you do to to
breach the door
and uh gives you the element of surprise
and let you in immediately
and so the concussion from that coming
back that's just the shock wave even if
you're not blowing off your feet you're
still maybe even able to operate within
two seconds of that happening well a lot
of times i mean you feel it but you
don't realize the long-term damage that
it's causing and so
you know any everything from
carl gustav rounds rocket launchers
um breaches explosives blown cars up
blowing bridges up blowing
you name it we've blown it up and in at
close distances and and
just a life of that you know just taking
that impact over and over and over and
over and over again i mean i think
you're only supposed to shoot
two or three carl gustaf rounds what's a
carl
it's a huge
rocket launcher
it's like if you think of bazooka that's
what the carl deuce and what what do you
use it for
you can use it for anti-personnel guys
and caves
you can use it on vehicles you can use
it all on all kinds of stuff they're
kind of outdated now now they have the
javelin yep but um
in my day that was just
just kind of showing up well i suppose
what i've seen of the javelin it sort of
jumps out of the barrel and then seems
to take off is that right is that how
the javelins work so i'm going to guess
one of the elements that that will be
for is to try and protect the operator a
little bit more so that you don't have
that immediate
explosion in the chamber itself yeah
i've actually i've never shot a javelin
so i don't i can't speak from experience
from that i'm too old for that
but um
but the gustav is some heavy impact in
the breaching charges or heavy impact
and getting blown up and hides heavy
impact and
and um anyways that's where the brain
injuries come from you joined when you
were 18 right
what
what was the predisposition that you had
there
and what what was learned behavior that
you got throughout your entire career
i'm trying to work out which bits of you
remained and which bits of you were
deprogrammed through two decades of
being an operator
that's good i don't um what about the
aggression like was there aggression in
there was there this shortness was there
this over
reliance or over um
importance on everything
being a big deal was that always there
no that was learned that came
um
there's a lot of pressure being on a
team
and
the pressure is
don't let your team down and so
everything needs to be done if you're
not doing anything you should be doing
something make yourself busy go
you know get x y and z done
and so
and when you do let the team down
you know it and it it's it's a horrible
feeling
and and they let you know that too what
were some examples of a time when you
did something that you felt was letting
the team down
um
on my first deployment
i was booze hound we weren't we did not
go to war
and i was pretty upset about that and so
i took to the booze uh very heavy but we
still needed to train and we still
needed to
keep sharp and we needed to be ready in
case we needed to relieve a platoon you
know if uh if they took
casualties and my booze and got out of
control and the platoon let me know
immediately
uh that it was getting out of control
i woke up with a couple of them
surrounding my rack where i was sleeping
and uh
in the middle of the night
and uh
and you're half cut at this point
still half wood cut like oh no i was
sober here okay this was a night when
you hadn't been yeah i was sober here
and uh
you know they tune you up a little bit
what's that mean
kick your ass around a little bit okay
you know you know hey
you're [ __ ] up and you need to get
your [ __ ] together physically yep
wow so this is an enforcement mechanism
that's commonly used
used to be very common um now i don't
think it is
as common but um yeah it used to be
no questions asked if you're
if you have a problem and
it's it's
getting in the way of the team
then you're going to be dealt with
some full metal jacket
[ __ ] that's what it sounds like yeah
how do you go back to being
an effective pairing in a team
after
a bunch of people have just woken you up
in the middle of the night and kicked
the [ __ ] out of you well you you know
it's not
like i said it's not uncommon you know
it's it's it was very common and so
you never really i mean as much as is a
disappointment uh
as you are there's no time for
there's no time to dwell there's not
really any time for grudges
and everybody gets out of line
eventually you know so i wasn't the
first one that happened to i wasn't the
last one that had happened to
and um so you can't take it personal you
just need to be and they do that in
training too you know i mean you're
broad
like i said or like you said i joined
when i was 18.
and so this all starts day one yep you
know in buds and you're letting
you're letting the team down because
even though it's not technically
you know a seal team you're still
you're training with
a handful of guys and if the instructors
call you out and they're like all right
we're gonna run that four miles again
because sean didn't want to put out he
wanted a half-assed
then you have your entire class that
[ __ ] hates your guts because they're
going to run that four miles again
or
you know whatever evolution it is we're
going to run the o course again we're
gonna get back in that cold water again
until somebody quits because
so and so was cheating wow so they'll do
they will single you out in front of
everybody and so by the time you get to
the team you're used to that yes and
they do it even if
if you're in buds you may be the fastest
swimmer
and
if they see that you're not helping
somebody out helping the team out but
you finish first they're going to pull
you out and make everybody do the swim
again except you
because you didn't help anybody
so you're going to be sat on the
sidelines which makes you look like even
more of a dick while everybody else is
suffering
did they do that during buds where
they would put everybody in the water
until someone quits
yes
that seems like such a brutal practice
it is
i don't think that that's actually the
the that's what they tell you but
everything in buds is
um
it's
very structured it's they don't have
time to because if nobody quits
yeah
and you're not going to test people on
whatever else they need to yeah that's a
good point somebody will always quit but
then when you get you know farther into
buds especially like the third day of
hell week it starts getting harder for
guys to quit because you're already
zoned out and you've gone through 75
percent of the quitters already yes and
so when there's only
you know 25 guys left in the class out
of 250
those are your they aren't going
anywhere you're a lot more bound
together as well i suppose you know one
person leaving from 250 versus one
person leaving from 25 yeah is gonna
there's more pressure on them
yeah that's so what else
what else changed from you you at 18 to
you
several decades later
attention to detail changed a lot
i think i was not attention to detail
before i went in now i'm ex very
attention to detail because
getting tuned up missing minor mistakes
or or
not even necessarily half-assing things
but just missing
small things or or you forget something
but and the stakes are incredibly high
yeah
um
a lot has changed a lot has changed my
temper has changed my how so
uh before the psychedelics i would get
very i would say i was angry more than i
was happy
you know
um
experienced a lot of loss use
a lot of trauma in a in a job like that
and um
makes you angry makes you angry
to see people take this country for
granted you know after all the
sacrifices that you've seen that you've
made that
friends died you know what's an example
of that
well you got angry about people taking
the country for granted
self-entitlement
is a big one
you know you see a lot of people
right now we see everybody
getting college tuition you know paid
for
with the new administration which on one
hand i think that's great you know
because we're finally somebody's pumping
money back into our own country instead
of sending it all to ukraine and
everywhere else in the world but um
on the other hand
you know there's got that was an
incentive you know for guys to join the
military hey you join the military we'll
pay into the gi bill will take care of
your college
well now that's not worth [ __ ] because
college is free
so how does that make it feel is that
what's actually happening now i thought
that it was a ten thousand dollar i
think it's difficult i'm not i'm not too
familiar with the with
the bill okay you know they're coming
out with so many of them i can't keep up
anymore but um
but i know i've seen a lot of people
that i know i saw one guy post on his
twitter you know
that his tuition was his legs
and it makes them sick that
they're going to pay everybody else's
and this is somebody that's got double
prosthetics yep
yep
so anyways you know and then they
complain more well you need to pay for
this you need to pay for this i'm
entitled to this i'm entitled to this
and you come home and that's that's
that's what you see because that's
what's in the in the media
you know and it can build for me
it builds resentment
uh a lot of guys i think can can
overlook it i'm still working on that
psychedelics have helped a lot i think
uh
if you've made huge amounts of
sacrifices whether that be physical
psychological
social
familial
inevitably you're going to feel the
delta between how difficult life has
been for you and the things that you've
had to go through
and the supposed victimhood of other
people i'd it makes complete sense that
that would be the sort of thing that
would get you angry yeah
and the psychedelics have had a
significant impact on major impact major
it doesn't matter you know
that's what it taught me is that
you can't control it and it doesn't
matter
i mean you're a smart guy though you've
learned about stoicism and the dichotomy
of control and you know you can't
control the things you can't control so
focus on the things that you can
is there a limit logically rationally
that you can get to like you can read as
many ryan holiday books as you want
about stoicism but it seems like
you this was a problem you couldn't
think your way through you actually
needed something to kind of take you an
exercise i was letting all of it get to
me i was letting people kneeling for the
flag you know
we come does that go over there
oh yeah that was a major trigger for me
watching people kneel for the national
anthem
i was it was
it was huge for me i mean i
i can't count how many funerals
that i've gone to where you know guys
have died
for this country
and then you come home and you got
athletes making 60 million dollars a
year
you know what do they have to complain
about
kneeling for the national anthem
i mean
it's it's
sickening
you know and it bothers a lot of us
um
i may be a little more vocal about it
but i'm gonna guess
most veterans don't have the same sort
of platform as well
you know yeah
they don't
but those are some of the things you
know that you you come home and and
and you see that stuff you know you see
all of it you see writing in the streets
you see
what the lawlessness that you guys were
trying to
keep out of here and now it's right here
within
yeah the coal's coming from inside the
house so yeah
okay so
seals you get through that you only do a
few years in the sales is that right how
long six years six years yeah uh
then you decide to pivot
from the seals
to the cia what led to that decision
actually i pivoted to a real estate
agent after of course and uh that did
not that went over like a farting church
but uh i just didn't have the
communication skills and i was coming
right out of uh iraq at that time what
was the reason for leaving to go do real
estate money
the reason i left uh the seal team the
big reason is
i saw
i looked at all the older guys that have
been around for a long time and i
started realizing none of these guys are
married
most these guys don't even know their
kids
most of them come home to a black lab
every night or some type of a dog pet
you know and and
i could see how lonely
that would be
and so i decided i don't want to spend
my entire career here because i want to
have a family
and um
at least i thought 24 24. there's a lot
of self-awareness going on there yeah
well i mean you grow up real fast you
know on the seal teams that's you know
kind of what i was talking about earlier
and uh so i saw that
and that was a major factor
another thing was i started seeing
politics uh come into the seal teams and
i didn't like that how so it was
it was
when i went to my first combat
deployment was right after red wings
happened the red wings for the red wings
was uh the marcus latrell
uh lone survivor have you seen that
movie that was red wings
came in uh relieved them and
whoever was up higher you know
was pulling us off missions
literally just saying uh you're not
doing that you're not doing that they
actually ended the entire afghanistan
deployment for all seals early
that was my deployment so i volunteered
to go to iraq
and i that was just such a
disappointment
at the time because
you train hard you know
to go and do that job and when you show
up and you don't do the job that you've
been training for very much and it's
happening everywhere around you
that is infuriating
and and
so that that was a that was a factor
that had to do with politics
um
but the major thing was the family stuff
i just i saw it
and i didn't want to i didn't want to
end up with the 45 years old coming home
to a black lab and that's it i had this
uh idea i thought about a little while
ago so the place that i grew up in the
uk was fantastic mom and dad were
amazing but it was
not a lot of people were like me
necessarily and not a lot of people were
living the sort of life longer term that
i felt was right i didn't really know
that it was wrong but i just felt like
there was something off
and i was thinking about a lot of the
time
i'll hear from people who
don't have role models around them and
that's why they resonate with stuff that
they consume online because they finally
get a community of admirable people that
they can look up to that maybe they
don't feel like they've got in their
local environment but what i realized is
that
a negative role model an example of
someone that you don't want to be like
is just as useful as someone that you do
because you can get a long way in life
by just avoiding
disaster and catastrophe in fact you can
maybe even say that avoiding it is more
important than getting things right like
not getting something wrong is a bigger
deal than trying to get something right
because they're getting something wrong
will make you absolutely miserable
whereas they're getting something right
you still can you can still [ __ ] up so i
think being around guys
who maybe didn't have that foresight
because i'm going to guess let's say
that someone's 45
they the seals haven't been around long
enough for them to have had another 20
years of predecessors before them for
them to be able to see the trajectory
that they would maybe be on right well
also they weren't coming out they
we went through a long time period where
there was no war you know from vietnam
a couple things in between there
like somalia you know iran
um
panama when we pulled noriega out stuff
like that but nothing like ongoing like
vietnam so until from vietnam to
to september 11 2001 you know there
wasn't a whole lot going on there was a
lot chill yeah
and so
you saw this massive
transformation of what
a seal you know kind of i wouldn't say
looks like but um
it was just very different you know when
september 11th happened because then you
start seeing the trauma then it gets
very real you know prior to that it was
you know train hard play hard let's have
a good time let's drink some booze
there's not really anything going on in
the world now
this shit's real you know and and
you know what i'm saying so why
would you think that
the cia
wouldn't give you the same 45 year old
sean with a black lab
well
so
i did
but uh i got out
and i became a real estate agent i
couldn't stand it i hated it then i got
i i thought well i missed the
camaraderie so i got into a fire academy
i was going to be a firefighter
and then i realized
well i didn't realize they basically
told me that you're not going to get a
job for two years
after this it's the same in the uk and
and i started looking around and and
i realized
if you don't have a grandpa or a dad or
a mom
or whoever who is in the fire service
you're not getting in that's it's pretty
tight-knit and it seems to be very close
family ties in that service
and you know i was 24
and i had a house and i was like
man i got i can't sit around here for
two years hoping that somebody hires me
so
i had a friend uh who reached out and
wanted my resume and he was just like
hey you know it's contracting i was like
absolutely not i'm not doing contracting
i don't know what's contracting i mean
that was
con so when i was at cia was this i was
a contractor what does that mean
it means that you're not working
you're not an employee they can kind of
wash their hands of you
and um you're the most dispensable
people on the team yeah i mean the
majority of the agency is
contractors but it's easy to wash your
hands of them so it makes sense right
but um
but really for somebody like the
audience there's not really much of a
difference you know it's kind of just
paperwork
but
but anyways he's he said
i can't tell you who it is for you know
but just give me your resume and i
trusted him he was a he was a guy that
was in my platoon we did a couple
deployments together
and he's like it's not like these other
guys because i'd seen there's all kinds
of different contractors there's state
department contractors there's cia
contractors there's dea contractors
there's fbi contractors
and there's all these different
companies you know and and um
we would see a lot of the contractors in
baghdad when i got to iraq
and
you hear a lot of rumors
and and it just wasn't an outfit that i
wanted to really be around
i think a lot of it sounded like a lot
of the
lesser-known companies
were
kind of careless what they weren't as
professional
and uh they they were this was early on
in the worst they were trying to figure
out what kind of resume they were
looking for and everything and i just i
was like i'm not doing that you got
you got everybody from seals to the guy
that was guarding the bank of america
building
you know just the local bank and it
so you can see the gaps there
he assured me it wasn't like that
but
he said it was classified i can't tell
you so i pitched to my resume
probably didn't hear anything for about
six months and then i got a call that
was or an email that was hey
fill all this paperwork out here's 50
pages of a security clearance and be
here
with this equipment for a tryout
what was the equipment
it was just kind of um
holster
what kind of clothes you know what the
what the weather is going to be like
stuff like that
you know bring a belt bring
gun ulster bring
equipment to operate in
you know if you have it
so i put all that in there and went down
and said goodbye to the fire academy and
and uh wanda making it
so that's the select cia selection i
mean what is that
well
it's
it depends what job you're going for for
mine it was
a very intense shooting package uh
a lot tougher than the shooting packages
i was doing in the seal teams
and the difference between them i think
the major difference between
trying out for a slot like that at the
agency and and trying out for buds is
buds they know you don't know [ __ ] when
you show up you know and they know even
when you get done with buds and you show
up to the seal team they know you still
don't know [ __ ] you know and they're
there to train you
and heckle you and you know give you a
hard time and and just develop you
help you develop into the best operator
that you can be
when you show up for an agency tryout
they're expecting you to have all these
skills wired tight you know so there is
no let me help you with that
there's
perform this task to the best of your
ability and
we're gonna watch
can you give us an example of the sort
of tasks that were in there
um yeah like
shooting you know they would you just
everybody show up on the 25-yard line
okay there's your target
i want you to hit as fast as you can on
the buzzer boom and they have standards
but you don't know what the standard is
so you're just going to the best of your
ability so spread and speed and stuff
like that yep yeah all of that and it
it's the kind of
it would be the kind of shooting drill
that you're just not going to pass if
you
you're not going to pass it if you don't
know what you've been
[ __ ] about
fighting fires and chopping stuff and
practicing saving kittens out of trees
and going home to your house are you out
of practice at this stage yeah
how the [ __ ] did you pass then
i just did
you know i just i guess i just i was
still young you know and and i like
shooting you know so
i just blocked out and i think that
i think they wanted me you know because
they there's a reason they don't tell
you the exact standard
it gives them a little leeway if they
don't like you very nice yeah yeah yeah
and no one can say hang in a second he
got in but i didn't
even though blah blah yeah yeah yeah but
as you get in the standards become clear
because you do have to go through every
two years
or i think it's every two years like
psychometric evaluation yep make sure
you're still sharp yep and um but it's a
lot it's it's
it's a lot more cut down you know it's
it's
you don't have to display all of your
skills every single time
once you're in but that initial one is
how do you drive how do you work as a
team
how do you clear this room here's a
problem we want you to solve it there's
a hostage in there you need to go in and
get them and meet us at this restaurant
at whatever time you know and so
they're watching all of your
problem-solving skills they're what
they're watching how you work as a team
they're watching how you lead they're
watching
you know your tactics how do you how did
you enter the room how did you treat the
hostage
once you secured the hostage
you know what was your evac route why
did you choose that route did you notice
the guy on the corner that was taking
pictures of your car
and got this license plate right here
you know and and all that kind of stuff
has happened they're all we call them
ftx's field training exercises but
you're just constantly being evaluated
the entire time and
and
if you don't measure up then you're gone
there's no remediation there's no let's
work on this roll it back there's
you don't meet the criteria you're out
and that's it
going into the cia
i'm going to guess that their feeder
profile must be multiple different
organizations probably people from green
berets
marines seals
maybe like nsa maybe intelligence
operators or whatever perhaps not so
much for what you were doing but i can
imagine if someone happened to be an
unbelievable translator or something i
had great communication skills but then
you could shoot a bit maybe they might
try and put those in my point being that
it must be strange going from an
environment where everybody's been
trained differently
different cultures
different backgrounds
different understanding of what it means
to clear a room to communicate to maybe
even different call signs different
signals all this stuff
what
how do you get a melting pot of these
people coming from such diverse
backgrounds to function at all together
that's a great question
um and it is like that it's so the
program that i went into you had to have
six years
so i just barely made the requirement
you had to have six years of uh special
operations experience
and so you they're taking
delta guys
seals green berets rangers
and marsaak guys with some air force pjs
and cct guys
so everybody you know we all have the
same knowledge but it's just minor
differences
um the thing that really
got in the way at the beginning was
the
uh what's the word i'm looking for the
the rivalry between branches you know
the seal there's always like friendly
rivalry and unfriendly rivalry you know
we're better than them at this and did
it a lot of egos right a lot of aid
personalities
and um
so trying to figure out what the best
way to do things with
if i'm a seal
and you're a marsoc marine
who's
who's right whose style are we going
with what's the biggest difference that
you noticed who was trained most
differently or who came in with the
different the most uh
diverging opinions when it comes to ways
to operate
i don't think there was a specific
outfit that was like that it was more
the individuals you know than and there
were guys that
couldn't
there's guys that couldn't let it go
you know
like like seals it's like
you got to be able to let some of the
things that you learn to go and learn
new things when once you're in
you know it is it's a [ __ ] team again
and you have to blend in and you have to
function
and it's
a lot of times it's the real young guys
because their egos are going crazy and
then you got the real older guy the
older guys you know some of these guys
coming in they're 50
i've been worked with a 65 year old he
was the baddest 65 year old man i've
ever met
but
he's stuck in his ways you know he's
done the same thing over and over and
over again and has not changed and so to
change somebody like that it's hard and
then you got the younger guys
like me you know who did six years and
they think hey i'm
i'm the [ __ ] best at what i do i just
i'm a [ __ ] seal
and nobody gives a [ __ ] if you're a seal
they want to know that you can do the
job and that you can work as a team
and uh
but the majority of guys you know
it
they like to share you know their
experiences and and
and they like to hear your experiences
because they're learning they're they're
becoming more well-rounded
and um so once you're in
it
a lot of that kind of [ __ ] goes away
yeah because you're not a team at the
start right it's there's still a degree
of competition between you there's no
bonding there's no reason to do that and
i suppose as well
if there was two different groups that
felt like they both had skill sets like
i would imagine that if it comes to
demolition or water stuff most people
would think
might be worth
listening to the seal
but then if there's someone that's doing
shooting then perhaps there's multiple
different groups that have different
styles whatever it might be okay so you
you get through and then
what's the biggest change in terms of
the
the culture
cia seals the cia totally different
completely
cultured
totally different the hazing that kind
of stuff there's a 100 no go
there's no hazing there's no tuning
people up for [ __ ] up there's you're
working with women
you're working with
nerds
you know you're working with a whole
slew of different people in the seal
teams you're with 16 guys and
everybody's a meat eater everybody wants
to go to war
everybody's hardened everybody's in
shape
you move over the cia in in the outfit
that i was in under the agency
all those aspects are still there you
know with my immediate team but then
you're dealing with
you're dealing with spies you're dealing
with intelligence foreign intelligence
people you're d you got to wear a suit
sometimes you got to wear what you're
learning the seal team sometimes one one
day you might be meeting the president
of afghanistan
or
you know high-end diplomat uh from
another country and the next day you're
pumping the mountains you know in
afghanistan with an m4 i mean you just
the the the job is so
broad when you get over there yeah and
uh with the agency
how much does that feel like
did it ever feel like it was a nerfed
version of the world to you like it was
the
all of the sharp edges had been removed
and you were having to be domesticated
now you got to wear the suit you got to
say please and thank you you got to
smile or did you enjoy
the transition into a more professional
environment
i liked both you know there were times
when i missed being a hunter when you're
with 16 guys for two years straight or
six years or you know however you're
with your team
there's a lot of trust there and you
don't have to watch what you're saying
you don't have to watch your mouth you
don't have to worry about
any of that stuff you know and
when you move over to the agency you you
have to watch your mouth you can't be
cause someone will write you up talking
about
the girl you want to take home at the
bar at the end of the night there you
can't you know you just got to be a lot
more tight-lipped
and um that
took some time for me to get used to a
little bit of adaptation yeah but um
but i also liked it because it was a
more sophisticated outfit and
in the job was constantly changing for
example when i was in iraq it was
sniper op after sniper op after sniper
op after sniper op when i went to the
cia
it was all these different things
and you know what i mean it was it was
spying it was meeting people it was
getting dirty it was going out and in
gun trucks and humping mountains and it
was everything
from from the teams not all of it but a
lot of it with all this other stuff and
you just never know what the next day is
going to bring it was
really challenging and a lot of job
satisfaction i learned a ton i was going
to say is that the most fun that you had
during your career
yeah i think so
i liked both of them
but the agency was just
a little bit different
it was it was
i mean it's the agency you know you're
you're you're flying under the radar
you're you might be one of three people
in a country i mean it's just really
you're out there doing it on your own
and and
and with the seal teams
you know you've got
air assets you have drones you have ac
130 gunships you have apache helicopters
you have
um
military units that are ready to come
get you out if you get into trouble with
the agency
sometimes you have that
a lot of times you don't a lot of times
it's you and the few other guys that
you're with and or women
how does that feel to be one of only
three people perhaps in a country doing
some clandestine operation
knowing that you're a contractor that
the agency could
wash the hands of
for me i never really realized the
magnitude of it until it was over
know the best so yeah you're just so
busy
and embedded in what you're doing and
how important it is and running
all these different aspects of what's
going on there you're only one of you
know a few people
and it's not always like that
but
you don't have time to
think about
that kind of stuff it's it's just you're
in the you're in the moment all the time
you know boom boom boom getting things
together getting the next mission ready
and uh
it's
it's really cool
i love it i i did love that aspect of it
is that by design is the agency
continuing to um move you quickly with
momentum so that you don't get the
opportunity perhaps to to sit back and
think [ __ ] this is this maybe something
that i should be scared about this is
maybe something that i should be
concerned about
um not necessarily because you get
a choice you know sometimes you get a
choice sometimes what do you mean
well
for example
i won't get a choice on what country i'm
going to they'll brief me hey you're
going here
and you go to that country and then when
you meet with the leadership of that
country
then they may disperse you somewhere
else you know what i mean so
there are guys in
[Music]
this outfit that they like to be at
headquarters
where everybody's at they have bars they
have
women
men parties great food awesome gym you
know all the amenities you sleep in an
air-conditioned room you have your own
room
that's what they like to do yeah
i would always volunteer to go to the
harder spots
where it was
hey you know
you can stay here but we have this other
place you know
and you're going to be living on the
side of a mountain or you know or
something like that and there's only
going to be five of you
you're gonna be really busy and it's a
really dangerous area and
when i hear that my hands like
i'll do that one because i liked it i
like the job what i didn't like is being
around
your headquarters because it's it's
political you have to worry about your
say you have to worry about how you
dress you have to worry about who you're
talking to you have to
you know it's it's more about the
political [ __ ] not offending people
than it is about getting the job done
and all i gave a [ __ ] about was working
i don't care about the parties i don't
care about the women
i don't care about the gym amenities
i just wanted to work and uh you can
make a gym anywhere
it's nice to think
that there is a
role there
for different types of people
it seems to me like the seals
in reflection it seems like the seals
actually select for a very narrow band
of
uh capacities temperament
whereas the cia here
it seems like you you can have some
sledge hammers and then you can have
some scalpels and then you can have some
button pushes exactly
and they all work together
exactly
it's
you see a lot more of the impact that
you're making too because
you know in the seal teams you might get
a directive from the agency or from
higher up that's go do this but you have
no real
you don't know
what the guy you're going after was
involved in
or
with the agency you get a bigger picture
of what's going on in in in the entire
space so you understand the context of
why you're doing what you're doing i
mean how
it seems like you were pretty patriotic
before
going to the cia but obviously you're
being given this much broader view now
of how what you're doing contributes to
wider goals for america or freedom or
whatever it is that you're working
toward
was that
how did that feel did that did that push
that patriotism that sense of purpose
that sense of sort of
belonging and meaning that you had in
work absolutely
you're
you're previous to so much more
information
that
when you see it all the pieces come
together you're like oh this is why
we're doing this this is what this guy
does this is what he's going to lead us
to you know all these
all these things and and with the teams
it's
this is what we're doing doesn't matter
why go do it yeah you know and um
and so to have like that broader
spectrum but just
bigger picture it helps
in in
with what you're doing
what do you think the future of warfare
looks like
i don't think we're going to see a lot
of
ground wars
anymore what's that mean i think it's
going to be a lot of
like what china is doing now i think
it's going to be a lot of
cold war i guess is what you would call
it
where it's not in your face kicking
doors down it's not invading necessarily
i mean i know that's happening in russia
ukraine right now but
if major superpowers
start
fighting i don't think it's going to be
a lot of
ground i don't think it's going to be a
lot of marines i don't think it's going
to be a lot of
special operations i think it's going to
be a lot of
computer stuff hacking
propaganda
stuff like that
i think so you go from or
you know
yep
and there's the other option yeah this
but
i mean now it seems like all these
superpowers are starting to come to a
head and i
that looks very very different than
taliban al qaeda al-shabaab you know
things like that you're concerned at the
moment about the state of global
geopolitic
peace and stuff
yeah who isn't i yeah i do you're a
specialist right you understand this to
a greater degree than me who's like the
headlines look good this week or had the
headlines look bad this week yeah well
let's look at china are you familiar
with some of the stuff that's going on
yeah i mean give everybody a little
overview of what they need to understand
about what you think is important well i
mean
china's doing exactly what they should
be doing you know for their goal i mean
the fentanyl crisis that's happening
with the cartels and that's all coming
from china china's teaching they're
bringing chemists in they're teaching
these cartels how to cook
the world's most potent fentanyl they
are they actually already have the next
drug that's worse than fentanyl they're
teaching them how to do that but
china cold
no i don't okay but there's something
out there which is more lethal more
addictive it's already being introduced
and um
you know
and so that's eating is look at you know
i just walked around austin there's all
kinds of
homeless out there shooting shooting
drugs you know it's in every city it's
everywhere
and
that's coming from china you know then
you look at the
green
you know the green initiative we're
seeing this is what's going to happen
you know is
and i'm not necessarily anti-green you
know i'm all about what's best for the
planet but
you know we keep talking about oh we're
going to be energy independent with
green energy no we're not we're not
going to be energy independent because
china is going to supply
all of our energy equipment
and so
they're going to be able to do exactly
what russia is going to do to germany
this winter they're going to slip the
switch and they're going to say goodbye
to gasoline and they're [ __ ]
and that's what's going to happen to us
if we have china produce all of our
solar panels all of our lithium
batteries all of our
wind you know equipment all they have to
do is flip the switch and let's be
honest i mean how many products have we
had come in from china that last not
very many you know
the quality control over there they
don't give a [ __ ] about that stuff and
so they're going to control our energy
whether we like it or not because we're
not making that stuff they're buying up
our farmland they're paying off our
politicians
i did an interview on that on how many
of them and it's not one side you know
that's that's another thing that is a
little concerning is everybody
they're dividing us you know bipartisan
clandestine work they're they're
dividing us and they're doing a damn
good job a lot of the [ __ ] that you're
saying on social media it's a bots
you know and and it's it's designed to
split this country apart and they're
it's working i learned that the
second biggest facebook page before the
blm movement started
was begun in the internet research
agency in russia
that was where it was founded and they
were organizing rallies around the us
with real people turning up to them but
it was being organized from the ira it's
crazy right when you think about it and
so that
to me is the new warfare
and it's
in
that like i said they're doing exactly
what they should be doing for their
goals we are not we're worried about
you know woke [ __ ] or whatever well
there's a question here uh
there's a really important question i
think to be asked when you look at the
long-term isn't future
of whether or not
a democracy
is
compatible with long-term effectiveness
of a country
i don't like the idea of living under an
authoritarian regime but if you say look
you can either have a
freedom with a loss
or you can have varying degrees of
authoritarian authoritarianism with a
win you go there there literally might
be a position where you get to
where
by allowing everybody to have a say and
by giving people the opportunity to
uh get on their
step and start shouting about whatever
their particular current grievance is
that might be the thing which means that
the authoritarian regime ends up winning
you go okay so if that's if that's the
situation
how do you push back against that
because there's no one
no one's going to accept
a
decrease in their
civil liberties
simply because there's someone else
that's using a different set of rules on
the other side of the world
but i do think it it's not outside the
realm of imagination that it literally
could be that a ccp style authoritarian
regime is simply more effective you go
okay well you get to go down swinging
but
you go down yeah
i hope that doesn't happen
sometimes i sometimes i wonder if they
both lead to the same place i mean
um was it stalin that said
capitalism will eventually eat itself i
can't remember if that was him maybe but
um
and if you if you look at some of the
stuff that's going on you know like
amazon or walmart or
um
facebook
you know
they've grown so big and we are
capitalists right here in the us
well they've just obliterated small
business you know nobody's
when's the last time you went to
a best
buy you know or
it's destroying business and so
basically
i'm wondering if that's going to become
an authoritarian you know government oh
because you've condensed power into the
house
simply because of market dynamics yeah
maybe i mean the the free market
was a lot more free before the internet
because you weren't able to leverage as
well you know it didn't matter that you
had the biggest store
in
bastrop because austin was 20 miles away
and you it would take too long to build
up new customer bases and the brand
didn't mean anything to anybody or
whatever or definitely from state to
state
but yeah when you have the unlimited
scalability that's afforded by the
internet it does condense power into the
hands of very few and that's an
interesting point that
um if you run
capitalism forward
for long enough
with a sufficiently scalable technology
where the costs of increasing leverage
is sufficiently low you do end up with
an oligopoly because all of the power
ends up just continuing you just compete
away compete away compete away and then
don't get me i [ __ ] love amazon i
have amazon prime i buy stuff off there
all the time
you know it's just too convenient but
that's
that's precisely why it happens the
reason that it happens is because the
economies of scale afford them the
ability to be able to do this
um
yeah that's
it's interesting to think about right it
is yeah i wonder whether
i wonder whether longer term
there is going to be a pushback against
that i
i just i i think that people have become
so accustomed and this is me speaking to
myself with convenience
that
the anchoring bias pulling somebody out
of a situation in which they've got all
of that convenience and saying actually
maybe you should wait five days for your
groceries to arrive but you'll be
supporting local business i don't want
to wait five days for my groceries to
arrive i want them tomorrow like i know
i can get them tomorrow so why would i
go to a less
efficient
purchasing the only way i think people
would do that is if the quality is
better yes you know so
like
a lot of people do do that with you know
they'll go to a farmer's market and get
or
real organic you know or they'll go to
a farmer
like we do and we'll get real
not that the other beef's fake but i
know where it's coming from and i like
the cuts and
that you know what i'm getting at yep
but
you moved into personal security after
you left the cia this is something that
a lot of people take very seriously here
in america
what do you think most people get wrong
when they're thinking about
their personal security setup
it'll never happen to me
that's the biggest thing that they get
wrong they don't prep their weapon the
right way they don't train with it
enough because they don't take it
seriously because they haven't seen it
happen
um
i think that's the biggest thing
another thing that i see or
when you get into the industry a little
bit deeper and you have the the people
that make that a lifestyle
is
they get more than they need
and
and
they buy all this equipment and they
don't learn how to use it because it's
complicated you know i've
when i used to teach
people personal protection and stuff
they would these guys would show up
you know with lasers with scopes with
all these things and they don't even
know they they can't even sign them in
you know and um and those are the ones
that are coming out that
are asking for help a lot of people just
put these together and they just blow
money and they they really don't know
how to use them
and uh i think that's a mistake too so
people are replacing because you're
asking about actual like products right
yeah okay but also in terms of mindset
mindset is a major one that's the
biggest one
that's the biggest mistake they don't
believe that it's going to happen to
them they don't believe that it's going
to happen or
which the people that come usually do
but well they know
that it's going to right like oh you
mean in terms of training sorry i was
thinking in terms of a an assailant or
you know some bad guy that's going to
try and do something to you
there is an asymmetry in that
interaction because that person's
already made the decision that they're
going to rob your house or try and
attack you in the street
they know that it's going to happen
there's so many mindset things that
people paint these they paint these
scenarios in their head and that's how
it's going to go down and it's not going
to go down like that you know and you
see that
not just in personal protection but all
the way
to a lot of people think things are
going to happen here you know
and
they think that it's going to be one day
it's going to be all right we got to uh
you know we got to fight for the country
that's not how these things happen it's
a slow rollout and it gets very
confusing
and you mean like a civilian militia
that's going to push back against
whatever regime yeah whatever or if we
get invaded by china or whatever happens
you know
and um call it the zombie apocalypse but
you get these guys and they think that
one day that the zombie apocalypse is
going to happen we're going to get
invaded and and it's going to be
you need to eliminate everything that
wears this or looks like that or it's
not how it goes down how it goes down is
very slow and it's confusing and you
really have to pay attention to target
identification
because
the whole world just doesn't flip you
know at once
another thing that i see a lot or
you know people don't they want to get
real big into
shooting and they want to prep for the
end of the world or whatever
and
they they put so much emphasis on that
but their physical their 150 pounds
overweight
more people die of a heart attack every
year than anything else and they don't
have an aed and they're 150 pounds
overweight you know an 80 defibrillator
and it's like that's great that you're
you know getting ready for all these
things that might happen maybe one day
but you're 150 pounds overweight and you
don't even know how to use a
defibrillator
you know and
they don't like it when you tell them
that but that's the real threat that's
the most imminent threat you know to
that person they don't like it when you
tell them that or
you get somebody that's
a lot of overweight stuff here but you
get i'm just gonna jump on my rooftop
and uh with all my guns and it's like
how the hell are you gonna get up you
know
but um
i mean i'd like to see a try but
a lot of that a lot of that kind of
stuff with in in painting the scenarios
where
if i if somebody attacks me in a parking
lot this is how it's going to go down
that's not how it's going to go down
it's
it's
before you
engage somebody i mean there's so many
processes that have to go through your
head who's standing behind that person
are you going to shoot them can you
actually shoot this person
you know are they doomed to you what you
think they're doing to you like it takes
time to process that's why you said
stuff targets
identification target identification is
so important
you have to process all these things
that are happening and within
seconds
and
most people it'll be done
and gone before they even realize what
the hell happened so
does that make sense absolutely yeah
what about um when it comes to people's
homes
what are the things that you wish more
people knew
about personal protection
in the home around the home
just
i mean basic stuff you know um
a dog
like
to protect your house a dog is the
number one deterrent for anything for
any any fbi statistics pointed that for
years and years and years is that right
yep a dog is the number one deterrent
but um
i think the biggest thing with with
home security nowadays is the internet
you know people are posting you can map
your whole house out you know if you
follow certain people on instagram
especially some of these influencers
if you pay attention you can map their
whole day that's making videos and
behind them is the
window that's latched in the kitchen to
vent the fumes out or whatever yeah okay
yeah
or they post where they live and then
you can look it up on realtor.com and
there's the whole layout there was a
video uh that i saw recently about a
gang in the uk
who was using social media to steal from
influences houses there was this girl
that was on a reality show a few years
ago called molly may and uh she had
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
jewelry stolen from her house because
she'd
put it on instagram obviously as you do
because that's her job
and uh yeah a whole host of stuff was
taken out of her house they knew when
she was out of the house because when
her instagram stories
look at me i'm in cancun mexico that
means no one's in your house how long
are you down there you know
so
you know and they got yeah you're right
they got 200 000 a million two million
people following them and they're
posting
hey i'm in cancun there's a few thieves
in there that would love to have that
nice rolex yep
yeah okay so i think those are the
biggest mistakes that people make you
know they take home security so uh
uh
and then it's these stupid little
mistakes hey i'm out of town
and nobody's watching the house or or
you know like right now i'm in austin my
wife and kid are at home i'm not telling
anybody
on social media that i'm in austin until
i get home
and then i'll and then i'll tell them
yep
yeah very smart so uh tim ferriss wrote
this article called 13 reasons not to
get famous
it's a very interesting problem to have
that almost no one is going to encounter
what happens when you overshoot fame you
get too much exposure but tim's had a
billion podcast plays more probably one
of the ogs of this world
and uh he was talking about how after a
little while
he had to never post holiday photos
until after he got back because people
would ring the hotel that he was staying
in all of the hotels in the area that he
was staying in and asked if tim ferriss
was there then they would turn up there
was a guy that camped out front of his
house for
a week because he was adamant that tim
was sending him secret messages in his
podcast saying he wanted to be with him
so this guy found out where tim lived um
all sorts of stuff that he has to do now
to kind of future proof himself and
again this is a problem that very few
people would have but it's it's also
kind of not what you're seeing is
a person who has an unbelievable net
that they are attracting potential
uh bad actors in from well everybody has
that it's just varying degrees and what
you're basically doing if you have a
smaller audience of people that follow
you but you continue to do the same
things is you're just rolling the dice
you're saying look well i'm not tim
ferriss therefore i have nothing to
worry about you know if you've got a
private social media with 500 people on
there and almost all of them are your
friends i think
you can probably feel a little bit more
secure that that's not the case but if
it's a public social media yeah i mean
that makes complete sense and for tim
you know he was
how seriously he takes personal security
rogan as well man like
that guy does not [ __ ] about with
his security
and
what you're seeing there are examples of
people that are kind of existing at the
close to the upper echelon of normal
people right before you get to
presidents and and
sports stars and ceos of companies and
stuff like that
it could be it could be anybody though
you know i mean
we're talking about famous people and
and uh you know i'm sure you deal with
some of that as well
but
it doesn't necessarily have to be famous
people it could be
let's say you live in a town of 6 000
people
and
you're the only
heart surgeon in town you're wealthier
than 95
you know of that town and your kid goes
to school and you do only have
50 people following you everybody knows
you're the wealthiest person in town so
the minute you go to florida to go to
the beach
guess what everybody in town
knows that you're gone
and they're gonna go right over there if
they want you know and so it could
happen on any scale
how do you advise people to deal with
threatening
others in public if you're on a bus or
you're on a tube i'm seeing increasing
videos of these
appear on the internet of someone that's
just being belligerent
somewhere in public and if you're in an
enclosed space where you can't get away
right now or maybe you can maybe it's a
sports game or whatever like have you
got advice for people and how to deal
with that i mean
yeah
the thing that i tell them do is just
avoid it at all costs i think
a lot of
these confrontations happen and and it's
unnecessary it's two egos going at it
and
like for example just happened to me
yesterday
you know we're sitting i was sitting in
the park i stayed at the jw marriott and
there's a park across the street
and homeless guy
asked me for something i was like sorry
man i don't have anything
and he got
irate
with me charged me was telling me i
needed to stand up and
and i was just like hey man just
you got to be careful you know um
you really need to be careful with
people that don't have anything to lose
when you have something to lose and so
the first thing i would say is just
get the hell out of there if it
if if there's any possibility of you
being able to exit that situation so get
off at the next tube stuff get out of
the next bus stop just
let it go you know i think a lot of
people can't just let it go
um
but if you're in imminent danger
then
i mean you have no really no choice but
to confront it in my mind and so
i would advise especially today you know
crime's on the rise there's rioting
not right now but it happens a lot more
than it used to
and i mean carry a gun gun's going to
give you that confidence especially if
you know how to use it you know and and
all kinds of different scenarios i mean
my wife was a realtor
in boca raton florida
showing
really high-end houses and it took one
time where she got in an uncomfortable
scenario with somebody that wanted to
come look at the house she didn't have a
gun
that never happened again
you know and so
i would i
i'm a huge gun advocate i really think
that if if you have the means to get one
you have the time to learn how to use it
then you should be carrying one
it's just different times today
[Music]
do you hope for a time when that's not
the case
absolutely
so i what i see
among some people
especially the sort of uber preppers or
the doomer optimists as they're
some of them are now called
there is a little bit of a degree
of glee
at the potential conflict that's coming
it's almost like they want it to happen
well those are the people i was talking
about earlier that are preparing for the
zombie apocalypse that are going to jump
on their rooftop
and
those people are living in a fantasy
land that
not been to war
they never will be i think that they
feel a void in their life because they
never went to war and so they're they're
like hoping for
some kind of crazy opportunity to
show all of the hours that they've spent
at the range or whatever it is yeah
there is a
that's an element
a very unique one that i've noticed
since i've been in america
that there are there is a contingent of
people that i think
uh relish the opportunity of a
ballistic conflict happening yeah
regularly
and the opportunity for them to put
for them to justify
their
preparation their money their time
their
sense
of belonging or
um
[Music]
righteousness about what they've been
preaching
uh and telling their friends about for
so long
and that yeah like i want to show that
all of the work that i've put in was
worthwhile yeah he's saying what what
you're saying is that you want to shoot
somebody somebody that's a bad guy maybe
or somebody that deserved it
but if you want to
that your threshold for when you are
actually going to
pull your weapon out to use it
is going to be lower than other people's
and that means that you're potentially
going to escalate the situation
sooner
than it needed to be
and that's what i get concerned about
that's one of the things that i get
worried about that
you know there's a contingent of people
out there that
very small contingent i'm sure that most
people are
doing their personal protection for the
right reasons
but they are doing it because they want
to prove something i mean
of course it's a valid concern
being 100 honest that's part of the
reason why i left that business model is
i was teaching um that kind of stuff and
i was teaching very advanced stuff as
well and it it it got to the point where
i was like man the last thing i need is
somebody walking into a school wearing
my brand you know across their chest and
and i started i swearly started thinking
about like
what am i willing to teach somebody you
know why
why in the [ __ ] do you need to know how
to take an entire building down
you don't need to [ __ ] know that you
might want to know that but you don't
need to know that
and
and
so i brought my courses all down to just
basic fundamental stuff
think about it this way i've never
thought about this before but that's so
interesting think about the fact that
you restrict the
the government mandates that there are
certain types of weapons that aren't
allowed right you can't have a rocket
launcher i'm gonna guess uh you can't
have certain types of automatic firing
weapons you can't have maybe even
particular bullet sizes and grains and
stuff like that right there are certain
things that you're not allowed to have
claymores [ __ ] i'm gonna guess
but no one's stepping in as far as i'm
aware
to restrict the type of tactical
knowledge that someone's allowed to know
you know if you've got some retired guy
from the
seals and the agency
you have
the
cognitive equivalent
of an arsenal
of things
that civilians should not potentially
have access to because they're in the
wrong hands though unbelievably
dangerous and like why is it that you
can't have a thousand grenades in your
garage well it's because nobody really
should need that i would hope and also
that it's just dangerous and lots of
things can go wrong
but if you know the equivalent of a
thousand grenades in a garage and you
can give that to somebody
that's a
that's something that nobody's talking
about that's somebody that no one's
something that no one's mandating for
yeah
it's gone through my head several times
you know and um
i'm
i'm glad that it's up to the
professional you know that's teaching
what they're willing to give up and what
they're not willing to give up but
you know
some of them may regret that one day
what they gave up
you mentioned earlier on that you've
been through a good bit of grief um
a lot of people the first grief that
they're going to feel will be you know
parents passing perhaps or
dogs or friends when they're younger
what have you learned about the process
of grief and and dealing with that
everything passes
it's going to hurt there's no way to get
around it
i think a lot of people
feel a lot of guilt
you know you might
everybody grieves different and
you have to know that it's going to pass
and when it does pass you have to be
okay you know that it has passed
because i uh
a lot of people will feel
guilty
that they don't have more emotion
uh
about
whoever that was close to them that just
passed or has passed but you have to
think about what that person would want
for you do you think that
your best friend when he dies you know
do you think he's gonna want you moping
around for the rest of your life feeling
sorry for yourself and complaining
that your best friend just [ __ ] died
or do you think he wants you to live
your life to the fullest and
if he's a good friend then he doesn't
want you moping around forever he wants
you to live your life to the fullest
because
he can't anymore you know and and
especially with um
you know
some of the losses that the
vets take veterans is you know
you guys were fighting for something
over there you know we all were we were
fighting for freedom and and
so you need to come home and honor the
sacrifice that that person made and live
your life to the fullest and and
know that they're smiling down on you
you know when you're doing it
that's a beautiful tribute right that
the
reason for you being there is for the
freedom for you to come home and do what
you wanted to do
but if a byproduct of you being over
there and someone giving their life for
that is you coming home and no longer
being free because you're trapped by
emotions
yeah it's an interesting way to frame it
jocko said exactly the same thing about
um
the guilt that comes from no longer
feeling the strength of grief
that it's almost like you
it feels like a betrayal maybe of the
person that's passed like i i should
still feel terrible about this and if i
don't that's like a
betrayal to their memory yeah
have you lost anyone no so that's this
is why i'm larping my way through this
right like i'm observing i'm watching
this happen in other people's eyes but i
can completely see the dynamic and
absolutely see the dynamic i mean that's
so ruthless right because you end up
becoming
the architect of your own
misery yeah
it's it's
guilt man it's a
it's a real thing but
grieve grieve until you're until you
feel it going away and then and then be
happy that it's
that it's going away everything
everything is gonna be okay you know
you just always have to remember that
everybody dies
what has the transition been like for
you now
as a father
like stepping into that role you know
you've been someone that for best part
of 20 years was
a
varying sized hammer
hammering things
and now
like you can't do the hammering thing
with a crying child or with a late night
or an early morning although you might
be familiar with that like what's that
transition like has it softened you are
you finding yourself
becoming the cuddly teddy bear that you
never wear or something oh yeah
i love being a dad i
i think it happened at the perfect time
sometimes i like to say i wish it would
have happened sooner but i don't think i
would have been ready holiday board i am
turning 40 in about a month
so
but um
i love it it's it's changed
everything
you know it's
watching
my wife develop into
a
perfect mom is awesome
and just every day
my son is doing something new and you
know the other day just climb the stairs
for the first time
and it's just to see him
make all these different little
achievements and just just watching them
stand up for the first time or
it's just awesome you know and then that
that's a piece of you and um
and it also makes you scared you know um
what's he gonna be like what's he gonna
get into what kind of problems is he
gonna have you wanna protect him from
everything
and you can't you know you can't protect
him from everything but um
i'm still learning i'm i'm very new with
this so but uh
i just i love being a dad you've had
people
that you were responsible for previously
right the other members of your teams
that you were responsible for
but now it's a very different type of
responsibility oh it's totally different
even knowing that
even knowing
and saying you see the parents that
freak out all the time my kid's sick
they're going to the emergency room i'm
never going to be that guy right
my kid just got sick and
i thought he couldn't breathe
walk it off [ __ ] yep
you might think you're gonna be like
that but i'm not i'm not like that i'm
like
oh [ __ ] am i that am i the dad that's
being paranoid or am i that but it's
just
i find myself erring on the side of
caution a lot more than i'm used to yes
very interesting the stakes have been
raised now yes
fascinating well i mean what do you
think about all of the time i'm sure
you've spent
even before you started doing your own
stuff
in terms of coaching
that you would have spent a lot of time
teaching people things
guys specifically yeah now you've got
one i can't wait he's not at that he's
not at that age yet where i can start
doing that but i
i think about it all the time what am i
gonna teach him
you know
what life lessons yep you know am i
gonna what kind of wisdom am i gonna
impart on him and and and uh it's
it's always fun to think about i can't
wait man i'm not a father yet not as far
as i know at least and uh
i can't wait to be a dad as well like i
look forward to being able to take all
of the things that i've spent time
you know accruing for myself that i
really value and then
distilling them down into a bunch of
little
creatures
to try and help them to get past the
things that i felt held me back
to expedite them towards success to make
them feel happier and more fulfilled and
more present more loved and more all of
that
i can't wait like
there's something one of my friends said
this to me before he said that
he's now
engaged i think and then
it'll be marriage and then family i
think is kind of the trajectory for him
so he's like locked in on a set of train
tracks now
and he was very successful with his
business throughout his 20s and his
early thirties he's like do you know
what it is man
i realized that basically all i did
running my business and all the
self-development and learning in books
and stuff that i read all i was doing
was just preparing myself to be a good
dad
it's like [ __ ] that's cool that is cool
so cool what
do you think that's coming in the near
future for you
uh we'll see we'll see i i
i'm at the stage and right now where
life is so good and so fun
uh like this this genuinely is the
golden years i texted this to a friend
earlier on he's like how's everything
going i was like dude this is the golden
age for me like i'm just having
so much fun over here
i'm
doing exactly what i've wanted to do for
a very long time i get to we're gonna go
cold and sauna after this i'm gonna go
and play pickleball and then i'm gonna
go nail
six hours of work when i get in like
that's the life that i wanna live i
wanna contribute to a project i care
about and have a positive impact on
people's lives i wanna leave the world
better than i came in and have some fun
along the way like that's that's it for
me so
uh
the difference in the person i am now
versus the person that i was
certainly ten years ago
certainly five years ago and probably
even two years ago
there is a bit of me that thinks
i'll have to reach a an upper bound like
i'm going the growth is going to have to
slow down at least at some point or else
i'm going to be like [ __ ] thanos or
some [ __ ] it's just every single period
that i look back on is so much more
development than it was before
and with that in mind i'm
maybe similar to yourself like i'm quite
glad that i haven't had kids so far
reason being that i know my capacity as
a father now
is
twice that of it three years ago
and a hundred times that of it ten years
ago yeah so
there is a
strong
uh
justification i think for guys that
maybe still
man manchilds at age 30 which i
definitely was uh to be like look man
like just if if you if you're on the
right tracks like maybe just pump the
brakes a tiny little bit and get
yourself to the stage where because
think about the difference that you're
going to be able to have with that
child's upbringing with how much more
you're going to be able to enjoy it as
well because you're going to be able to
understand your emotions
three times five times as much you're
going to be able to not be as caught up
i mean you know think about even the
difference that you've had over the last
six months since doing the psychedelics
you know like and this is your son's
about one year old right yeah yeah so
you've seen both sides of
fatherhood
pre and post psychedelics i mean how
different is that
very different
i've
i am a huge fan of psychedelics now that
the treatment was that your first ever
experience the ebola
yes [ __ ] the best one you really went i
went all out first time
but um
but the the the benefits from that are
just i mean there's just so many you
know i mean i didn't even go down there
with any intention of
not drinking anymore
and i just didn't want it and it was
people ask me how i do it oh how'd you
quit drinking it was nothing it was
i don't crave it it wasn't a hard thing
for me to do it would have been hard
had i not done psychedelics but
when i did the psychedelics
i just i didn't
have any cravings i didn't
i'm not making a mistake you know i'm
not like look at me i'm booze free i
just don't want it yeah it's so the
easiest thing in the world yeah i mean
that's the stage
i never drank regularly as a club
promoter for a long time and that meant
i was around parties and stuff i'd drink
maybe once every fortnight ish but it
would be like a it would be a full send
but it would be like a fun party or we'd
do whatever we we go into a different
city or something
um and then
i took a break for six months and came
back for six months and it came back for
like
four started drinking again so i really
don't enjoy this that much anymore so i
had another break for six months loved
it
started drinking again for two was like
i'm just gonna do a thousand days i
wanna see if i can do three years ish
and uh
one of the most addictive things that
i've done is sobriety
uh and it's so strange one of the
problems that you have is as soon as you
say the word sobriety it alcohol's the
only drug where if you don't do it
people assume you have a problem so
it sounds like you're recovering you go
no i it's the same as being sober from
heroin it's the same as being sober from
spending too much time on my phone as
far as i see it sobriety is a
productivity tool for me but it's also
like an emotional enhancement tool it's
connection blah blah blah blah
and i just realized that for me
i much prefer life generally when i'm
not drinking yeah now i would happily
microdose psilocybin i would happily
um
carver right which is like this root
drink that you can have and it's the
most mild thing in the world like i'd be
happy to take that or i'd be happy to
take like a low dose of an edible i'm
such a [ __ ] with edibles as well my
point being
there are other ways for you to get a
little bit loopy or like nicotine gum
lozenges and stuff like that like if you
want to get a little bit of a buzz on or
change your state there are things to do
cold plunge breath work like there are
things that you do
and for me i just realized that alcohol
really didn't agree with me all that
much i just i don't not a massive fan of
the effects of it i don't if you
actually look at it as a profile of the
experience that you get
i don't think it's actually that fun
there are significantly more fun things
to do
with substances or with experiences
that have fewer detrimental effects both
acutely the next day in the next couple
of days after that and then long term in
terms of your health
and
they're going to make you feel good
genuinely good during the experience and
i
understand why people get hooked on
alcohol i understand it's an incredibly
addictive drug but for me it just
it wasn't that enjoyable it was just the
thing that was available it was fun for
me but you know what
so many
positive things happened after i quit
drinking and it's only been six months
but i mean
so you just you went from drinking
pretty regularly to iboga gone gone wow
drinking
a bottle a night you know bottle of wine
i used to drink a lot more liquor yeah a
lot more but um i toned it down it was a
bottle of wine a night
i don't really think it was a problem as
a good wine down but man i'll tell you
um to
the benefits i mean i don't know about
you but
i mean my business just went from
doing this to i quit drinking and it was
you know my podcast just went crazy and
um
and
i know that i'm developing into
the person that i'm supposed to be 40
years old a lot 39 years old you know
because that [ __ ] gets in the way it
changes everything 100 100 are you still
not drinking um
i i drink when i'm away now so i used to
have a rule where
the best way that i had for introducing
alcohol was if i was ever going on
holiday or doing a road trip somewhere
else i would allow myself to have a bit
i was doing 4th of july nashville 2019
watching a quarter of a million people
and country music with a half hour
orchestral accompanied fireworks display
it's like i'm not not having a beer here
right i'm raising a beer um
but i wasn't doing it at home i've now
got myself to the stage where i came out
to austin and it's very social out here
and everyone likes to drink and and go
and watch live music and stuff i've now
got to this stage where austin is also
within the bucket of like a place that i
don't drink in so i'm starting to build
that up over time but dude
it's it's so strange for me thinking
about sobriety next it's been such a
huge part of my life for
six years
and
when i talk about it the
increase in mental sharpness the
improvements in my sleep the
improvements in my mood the consistency
that you build habits at right the extra
time the extra money products energy you
have all of that stuff and that's not
i'm not saying that you need to stop
doing something that you find that is
fun like drinking or socializing or
whatever to replace it with
spending the night doing your tax
returns or whatever my point is that
i realized that i could supplement going
out and and drinking or the hangover
that
that time would have filled up as well
with something else that i genuinely
enjoy like going to play pickleball or
going for a hike or getting another
training session in at the gym or
learning a new sport or whatever right
getting rid of alcohol opened up all of
those opportunities to me and when i did
it at the time it was the it was the
single most impactful lifestyle change i
made all the breath work all the
meditation all the everything up
probably after the podcast was the
single biggest impact that it's had just
it opened up all of that time and
consistency and energy what do you think
the hardest thing
about
putting the bottle down was for you
frankly it wasn't very hard wasn't it no
no i had no dependency on it at all it
was a it was a complete lifestyle choice
the only slight thing that i came up
against was a little bit of social
pressure
and i think that for most people i call
it elective sobriety the closest word
that i've been able to find for people
that aren't doing it to
get away from a dependency but to do it
as a productivity strategy
the
most difficult thing that they're going
to encounter is peer pressure from
friends because
in a drinking environment that tends to
be social there is like an accepted uh
routine that everyone goes through where
the people that are drinking try to
encourage the people that aren't
drinking to drink
and
there was a
that's one of the challenges you come up
against but
even for me there man like it was so
easy because i was the club promoter i
was one of the lead guys of this big
company so we had a good bit of status
especially within the nightlife world
uh so even for that my pushback as soon
as i was firm twice like everyone
listened because they
i had enough status for people to kind
of just stop pushing but i understand
that if you have friends who are more
um inclined toward drinking
there's a whole host of reasons as to
why your friends start to encourage you
i mean they they might start to feel a
little bit of distaste the fact that
you're doing something that maybe they
wish that they could do
there's also an element i think that
when you go out drinking with other
people
they know that you're making a sacrifice
both now and tomorrow and in terms of
your health and in terms of money and in
terms of time
to be with them and if you stop doing
that
it kind of creates a venus scenario the
tribalism kicks in and there is a
distance that's created between the two
of you i'm sure you'll have heard about
the psychological experiments so they'll
bring people into a room they'll toss a
coin heads go left tails go right and
they'll say to the tails people over the
far sides what do you think about the
heads people they're like they're a bit
stupid aren't they like we're much more
we're much smarter than them my point
being that any opportunity for people to
be tribal and they'll do it and as soon
as you start to create an other out of
yourself that'll happen but the bottom
line is like
if your friends only want to have you
around when you're destroying your
health along with them then they're not
really your friends and if you find out
that you can only bear to be around your
friends when you're drunk then you
definitely need better friends yeah
that's that was the hardest thing for me
was
what do you do with all these friends
now because before it was
i just drank with them and now
most people that drink uh that much they
don't have any other hobbies
but do you have friends or do you have
drinking partners exactly
exactly i had a lot of drinking problem
uh partners
but um
so that was interesting
you know and there's still there's still
people some of them are my best friends
that i'm um you know we talk every night
sometimes and and
i wonder you know the next time we get
together what's that going to look like
now that i'm not drinking
because that our whole relationship was
built predicated on drinking human
alcohol together
yeah man i mean one of the best things i
think about this is that the
pre-conceived ideas about the ages that
people can make like significant
lifestyle changes at becoming a father
at 38 or 39 getting sober and getting
control of your emotions through
psychedelics at 39
all of these things are you know moving
from the uk to the us at 33
it's nice
i like the idea of
breaking role models especially around
age
age is something that you don't really
even think about until you're probably
like in your early 30s and you go
actually hang in a second workouts are
taking longer and i get tired on the
night time and i got to wake up to go to
the bathroom if i drink too much water
on an evening like just stuff stuff
happens
and then you realize well hang in a
second
the preconceived ideas i had around age
are coming for everybody
not everybody is going to deal with the
grief of a friend being blown up in war
and everybody's going to deal with
fatherhood even right not everybody
becomes a father but everybody gets
older everybody does
and uh yeah the more that i think about
it the more that breaking
stereotypes
around what you should be doing at a
particular age
uh and then also trying to reinforce the
things that you should be doing at a
particular rate you should have control
of your emotions
you should be able to
have a disagreement with somebody
without
you getting invested and
agitated you should be able to control
the substances that go into your body
you should be in charge of that i did
500 days without caffeine for the same
reason just because
i wanted to make sure that it was me
that was in control of them
and i was like yeah i am
have you done psychedelics
not therapeutically okay uh i've done
maybe between five and ten
uh psilocybin trips of varying degrees
um but i i know that i should do
uh and i know that it would be probably
something that would be very good for me
uh there is a degree of trepidation i
think just because i've spent so much
time speaking to people about them and i
know how much of a big lifestyle change
it is and you go what the [ __ ] on the
other side of this
there's almost a bit there's almost a
part of you that that thinks well if i
don't know what's coming and i don't
know the changes that might happen that
would almost maybe be a little bit
easier
but i know that this could be something
that could upend a lot of things and
life's pretty good
uh
yeah it's
i think that'll change i think i'll end
up doing
some therapeutic stuff at some point but
there's also still a lot of low-hanging
fruit i think to pick up without having
to assist it pharmacologically
uh
and
yeah i'm so fascinated by the human mind
and human nature of mind and everybody
else's and how everybody interrelates
and stuff uh sober
right so
um at the moment the world's a
sufficiently colourful place without me
needing to add anything else in just yet
good
john ryan ladies and gentlemen dudes i
appreciate the [ __ ] out of you where
should people go if they want to check
out what it is that you're doing now
just
google sean ryan's show
everything will come up
thanks man thank you i really appreciate
the opportunity thank you and you're
crushing it i appreciate that
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
you